go and on your smartphone this is talk
TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook says that a world
exclusive double-headed Jordan and
Michaela Peterson together for their
first major interview and completely
uncensored
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored
good evening Fernando welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensored Jordan Peterson is one
of the world's most famous and
controversial thinkers his daughter
Michaela is a star on her own right with
a Smash Hit podcast and her own
burgeoning Army of followers she's
nurtured her father through a near-death
experience which included an induced
coma in a Russian hospital and served as
a guiding hand behind all the decisions
that made him a superstar tonight I'm
bringing both of them together and I
started by asking Michaela for her
reaction to my emotional interview with
her dad on last night's show
well I've been joined Now by Michaela
Peterson of course Jordan's daughter who
was on Piers Morgan on censored recently
Michael I know you were watching that
last interview that I was doing with
your dad there and he got emotional at
the end of that what did you what do you
make of it when you see your dad like
that and why he was emotional in that
case
I think to tell you the truth I think
he's worn out from doing 10 000 things
every day even when we tell him to take
rests he doesn't take them so I think
that plays a major role
but also the way our lives have changed
has been
overwhelming so when he says he's
overwhelmed all the time I think that
that's accurate
yeah I mean Jordan was saying to me that
it's overwhelmed by the sense of
responsibility he feels and the
influence that he has now there's so
many people brings with it the burden of
that responsibility and it's something
he feels very acutely do you see that
with your dad on a daily basis
oh oh definitely if people approach him
on the street he gets emotional quite
frequently because the conversations are
emotional so people come up and say this
is how hard my life was and maybe my
life is still hard but I'm managing to
take it on
in a more positive way and I'm I credit
you for that
and he gets emotional and that's all
real and it's because it's an emotional
conversation so
I think that that makes sense
yeah I mean Jordan I
that is an extraordinary responsibility
what I'm thinking is I I see the two of
you here I read recently I think it was
some Tick-Tock thing I saw but it was uh
an old business guy and he was saying
you know the real definition of success
in life is not money or material things
or anything like that the real
definition of success is if you're a
father
and your kids when they become adults
and therefore can make their own
decisions
choose to hang out with you because they
want to hang out with you that's the
ultimate definition of success what do
you think of that theory
oh yeah that's that's right I mean I
would say I feel that acutely I would
say my wife feels that even more acutely
like she's so thrilled
if her kids want to hang out with her if
they want to do you know committed
things with her that she can hardly
stand it and I mean this is also one of
the great advantages of having a family
people just don't understand this there
isn't anything more important that you
will have in your life
then your kids period and and it's such
like we said we lie to young women so
terribly by telling them that their
career will be where will be where they
find the meaning in their life I mean I
have a stellar career but and I'm pretty
damn thrilled about it and I should be
but
it's it takes second place to my wife
and my kids and then to my extended
family as well and so and if you
organize I think that's true even if
your family isn't working that well and
it's definitely true if it's working
well
I mean why wouldn't you want to be
around the people that you love
that's sort of the definition of love
Michaela I mean I would imagine you've
had sort of a weird life in one respect
where for a long time your dad wasn't a
globally renowned figure right and then
he became one
uh what was that transition like for you
as his daughter to see your dad go from
your dad and an academic and a
psychologist and so on man to suddenly
become this sort of you know odd
Superstar of you know with an influence
over millions of people what was that
like for you
well completely surreal at the beginning
so I remember walking down Bloor Street
in Toronto when this first happened and
he was still a university professor and
seeing a picture of Dad on the front
cover of a newspaper and it said
something like Heil Jordan it was
something like that comparing him to
Hitler and it was the newspaper I used
to read on the Metro on the way to
school and I was like well I guess I who
knows how many lies I've been reading
from that newspaper
and then for the next
I would say I would say our family
probably only really stabilized in the
last year and a half
so it took
what is that six years
to kind of come to grips with what had
happened to my dad and at the very
beginning
he was kind of lost to the Internet so
everybody was wrapped up in this but at
the dinner table and whenever we had
conversations it was really focused on
what was the news saying was he going to
lose his job what was happening online
and it was hard to
focus on anything other than that even
if we said okay you know no media at the
dinner table it was still hard to focus
on anything other than that and I think
part of the reason I stepped in to help
you and Mom was to
have something I was also involved in so
that I could be part of the conversation
and I think my brother Julian probably
felt that to the same degree was okay
well I guess we've moved from kind of
having this normal more normal family
relationship to
I love the chemistry between you two
um I've got a younger daughter she's 11.
I've got three much older Sons along
their twenties one Thirty now very
different thing very special
relationship I think your father and
daughter but you talked there McKenna
about a normal
sort of family world I find it hard
Jordan to believe that the Peterson
family has ever been conventionally
normal
you want to go there
I feel like it was a lot more normal
than it is now that's for sure like we
still had school you had worked you had
a number of jobs so you worked a lot mom
was at home and we had more of a dinner
routine and a schedule so we had that
but I think things were still a little
weird now that I know what other
families look like more when you're
isolated in one weird family you don't
know that it's weird for a while
I think the depths of concern in in our
household and in my life made our
existence somewhat not
run-of-the-mill not typical I mean the
artwork in the house I suppose was an
example of that I mean Michaela grew up
in a house that were I don't know 300
paintings I suppose in our little house
I had Lenin fall on my head in my
bedroom when I came back it happened to
every team yeah you had a gigantic
picture of Lenin in your bedroom that
fell on your head is that what you're
saying
yeah it kind of just leaned over it
didn't crush me literally it was struck
down by communism
yeah
Jordan what kind of father do you think
you were when Michaela was was younger
because I'll get her the fact check it
playful playful yeah we had a lot of fun
I mean
the people I grew up with my friends in
junior high in high school and and even
later
all we really did was engage in
competitive bouts of humor like all the
status among the people I hung around
with was who could say the most
outrageous and comical thing and I
really like I've always really liked
little kids I really like playing with
little kids and I'm quite good at it as
my father was it's one of his sort of
Stellar traits the ability to he really
likes little kids and he liked me when I
was little kids so that was a good deal
and I really liked being with my kids I
really enjoyed playing with them I
there's very little that I would rather
do than play with little kids who are
well behaved it's ridiculously fun
they're extremely comical they have a
very clown-like nature they're
imaginative and they see the world
through fresh eyes and that's a great
deal and so whenever I had a moment when
I wasn't working I spent it with my kids
and and my wife and we we had a good
time I mean we had our troubles partly
because Michaela was so ill but it was
always play and humor and teasing and
but not mean you know like fun I mean
you have vicious senses of humor and so
that's great and I I had the same with
mine I know exactly what you mean
Michaela you've had periods in your life
as a family where your dad has probably
feared he may lose you you feared you
may lose your dad and you both may have
feared that you would lose your mum
Michaela and Jordan your wife I mean
you've had some extraordinary things to
deal with as a family how have you dealt
with that
we communicated we communicated a lot
yeah
and prayed at the end when it got really
tough
so that's interesting that's the way
through I told Michaela when she was a
little kid
I told her at one point when she got
really sick I said we had a very serious
conversation she wasn't a very old girl
I said look kid
you're going to have a very hard life
it's going to be brutal and this is
after we knew she she had the worst case
of arthritis that the Toronto sick kids
had ever hospital had ever seen that's
not a diagnosis you want to hear from a
hospital not a big hospital like your
child has the worst case of this illness
we've ever seen it's like what's her
prognosis
multiple early joint Replacements so
that's like painful degeneration
followed by early death oh yeah that's
not so good well so what's worse than
that
well what's worse than that is
adopting the role of victim becoming
resentful and turning against life
because then you get to have multiple
early collapsed joints followed by death
and you get to be ultimately miserable
and in hell at the same time so I sat
her down and I said look kid you can't
don't ever use your illness as an excuse
like it's going to be difficult for you
to do things difficult for you to get up
in the morning to go to school it's
going to be painful and it's even going
to be hard for you to tell when you can
do something and when you can't when
you're justified in saying look Dad I
just can't get out of bed and said don't
fool yourself about your illness because
then you won't be able to distinguish
what you can do from what you can do and
then you will truly be lost and she
listened you know I don't think you were
more than about nine or ten when we had
that conversation she listened I had a
conversation with my son and about at
the same time
you know and I said look kid your sister
is very sick and we're screwed and the
probability that I'm going to be able to
pay sufficient attention to you for the
next few years is like zero you're gonna
have to like face this and you're going
to have to grow up and take this on
yourself and you cannot be any trouble
because we've got enough trouble anymore
it's going to sink us and so he listened
and he was no trouble I mean how was how
was Julian with you when you were at
home
good very good
compassionate for somebody who's fairly
disagreeable right yeah yeah and he
stuck around he was at home I mean he
had lots of friends and he did his
teenage things but he came home and and
he helped and he was no trouble he had
these things to deal with but he took
care of them himself we have a clip of
you guys with Julian I think just
several years ago uh which will show
people just to show who Jillian is
and so one of the great ways to figure
out what to write about is well what
bugs you
notice that that's that involuntary
rumination that's the manifestation of
underlying complexes from a
psychoanalytic perspective so
something's on your mind poking you
bugging you it's like Jiminy Cricket in
in Pinocchio
that is really annoying
I knew that would bug you
it's a great it's a great clip we don't
see a lot of Julian you know he's not as
high profile as you two
um but you're a very tight family I mean
Michaela the way your dad taught that it
could be taken as being tough love or it
could be just a reality check of look
you can either spend the next few years
of your life feeling sorry for yourself
or you can crack on with life and make
the best of it which is exactly the
advice I would have given one of my
children in that position but how did
you feel at the time you were given it
well I think I remember that and I think
I was in grade two
so
um I would have been seven or eight I
was pretty little so
I didn't even like at that time I didn't
even understand what arthritis was I
thought oh great I have an old person
disease that's as much as I understood
and I didn't want to tell anybody about
it because it was an old person disease
and so I don't even think I had second
thoughts about anything dad said because
I was so young I just figured okay
that's my dad that's what he says I
should do then I'll do it I don't think
I thought anything more than that but I
do think that was instrumental in
getting out of chronic illness honestly
uh
yeah because you barely got out of it if
you would have complicated it up with
some additional stupidity some
resentment
well I think that's probably true in our
family in general I mean we didn't do
things perfectly but we did our best not
to be resentful and resentment is really
a killer I think if you would have
burdened yourself with victimized
resentment
you wouldn't have made it yeah you know
what I did rather than become resentful
uh and I don't know if this was a
healthy thing to do but I got really
angry I didn't get angry at anybody per
se I got angry in a
um it wasn't a feeling story for myself
but it was
what am I going to do to get out of this
that's how dare life do this to me
that's not who I am yep sorry I was
angry for a long time you know one of
the things you want to do is you want to
get your anger on your side you want to
put it inside instead of facing you and
stopping you you want to use it as
as a force that drives you forward and
you definitely did that you were pretty
implacable person you know it's
interesting listening to you both
talking about that because I had a
fascinating conversation a few years ago
with Joe Biden who had just lost his son
Beau to brain cancer and obviously he'd
also many years before lost his wife and
baby daughter in a car crash and his two
sons survived and were badly hurt and so
on and everyone knows the story but I'd
written a column and he's better column
about Beau Biden after he died because
he used to come on my old show at CNN
and I just said look this guy was an
amazing guy he'd been a state attorney
general he'd been an Iraq war hero he
had a lovely family he was going right
to the top I felt politically he may
even have become
president candidate perhaps and I said
he'll now be the the best president in
America will never know they could have
had and I wrote this column heartfelt I
liked him very much I thought he was
very impressive and Joe Biden called me
he's vice president at the time and I'd
never met him and he he had a 15-20
minute conversation with me and I asked
him
I said I've got four children I don't
know how you would ever deal with losing
a child you've had to do this twice and
you lost your first wife
how do you deal with it and he said you
know it's interesting he said as I
talked to you I have in front of me a
cartoon strip Hagar the Horrible
and it was in two parts and in one part
Hagar was on a boat that was floundering
on the rocks and he had his Trident and
he was Raising it to the to the the
skies in very stormy conditions and
shouting at the gods why me
and in the second part of the cartoon
the god shut back why not
and he said he got annoyed originally
when he saw that when his dad his dad
found it in a flea market he got annoyed
he thought it was insensitive and then
the more he thought about it the more he
realized what his dad was saying which
is you cannot rationalize what's
happened to you you can't try and work
out why it's happened to you stuff
happens like this to people all the time
uh and I in a way it's different but the
way that you talk to Michaela about her
condition it is kind of similar is that
you didn't waste time and energy trying
to rationalize this or explain why you'd
been singled out it was just a case of
it happened we've got to deal with it
well I went to Jerusalem with a friend
of mine Jonathan Powershell and palgio
is a very brilliant man
and we walked the Via Dolorosa which is
the root of Christ's passion with its 12
stations and each station is a kind of
is a is a is a microcosm of suffering
and then of course the entire journey
culminates in the most unjust suffering
imaginable and that's what the story is
the Christian passion is the story of
the most unjust suffering imaginable and
you might say well what does that have
to do with you and the answer is
that's going to happen to you there's
going to be unjust suffering in your
life and you're called upon to radically
embrace that and to say yes
and that's even the case if it's your
children who are called upon to make the
sacrifice that's the story of Abraham's
sacrifice of Isaac God calls on Abraham
to sacrifice Isaac and you know that
seems like a bit much but you you have
to offer your children to the world you
have to offer your children to be
destroyed by the world you have to say
yes to that radically full-heartedly and
the more you do that weirdly
paradoxically the more you do both of
those except that for yourself except
that for your children welcome it the
less
catastrophic this sacrifice has to be
it's so it's so paradoxical well you
think about it you know if you protect
your children unduly you weaken them if
you let them encounter the world and and
the micro tragedies that go along with
that encounter let's say they get strong
yeah and there's no limit to that
there's no upper end and and so that's
why in the judeo-christian tradition for
example you're enjoying to take up your
cross and bear it and to walk uphill
nonetheless and the reason for that is
there is no better alternative of course
you have to say yes to life and that
means saying layouts to some pretty
brutal realities
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think it's only one for one king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just cause their
skin folk don't mean they're kinfolks do
you believe you can win this war but
it's making me cry again they're trying
to force you out yes I feel betrayed
keep it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous it was
clearly something of the face of the
world so it was even more Unthinkable if
this nurse had misgendered somebody on a
board should have been out the door when
they first got together there were press
stories way TK team that would make her
a better princess of wealth could you're
not just just marrying the man you're
marrying the child
resonates with people Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election can we yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the world has watched on in sort of
mounting horror as this story has
unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls foreign
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
vote me off shorts
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
well I'm in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has Battalion
materials you don't drink never taken
drugs you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to an uncensor special
Jordan Michaela Peterson for the hour
and the next part we're talking about
Jordan's Rush of death including a
medically induced coma in Russia
what was that like for you Michaela oh I
cannot even describe how horrible it was
like I thought being sick myself was bad
because it was very bad I thought
getting off of antidepressants I went
through antidepressant withdrawal which
was just horrifying beyond belief I
thought that was bad
watching how sick my dad got was so much
worse than what I went through that
it was hard not to what what did I think
I literally you know what for some
reason for some reason when he got
really sick
I I thought I could just move to LA I
was in Toronto and I thought I could
just move to LA we didn't know what was
wrong with him he'd been to a number of
different hospitals and my mom had been
sick and I thought I could just move to
LA and I could do things by myself and I
don't have to deal with this and then uh
I I thought about it and I had this
weird feeling that whatever was wrong
with him which I thought was
antidepressant withdrawal which is what
had happened to me would last about two
years so I sat down and I decided okay
I'm gonna do whatever I can to help this
guy and I think it's going to be
absolute hell for a couple of years and
I don't know why I had that feeling but
I had this feeling of this two-year
period and so I decided rather than
running away which had definitely
crossed my mind uh I'd do everything I
possibly could and just put my life on
hold until he got better which I figured
was about two years so while this was
happening particularly when we were in
Russia I was like at that point I was
literally learning Russian I was like I
don't know how long we're gonna be here
Russian is not easy to learn
um but I was like I you know made a
commitment I'm gonna help and see this
through and I believe that he can get
better so I think the way I managed that
was I had a really strong belief that
he's sick but he can get better and I
just have to stick with him until he
gets better and nobody could change my
mind from that not even him even though
he tried it's like I'm not gonna make it
like yeah you are you're gonna be fine
you just gotta get through this so I
think that's what what helped was a
naive optimism of getting better I mean
it's fascinating Faith fascinated to see
the roles reverse there Jordan but then
you both had to deal with your wife
getting very sick with cancer your mum
Michaela
um and you both had to deal with that
what after given what you'd both been
through
what was that like for you as as a unit
the pair of you and of course uh Julian
in two
well it was remarkable to see her deal
with that really to see how many deal
with that because Tammy's very very
tough person and even she got the news
initially that she had a form of cancer
that was a hundred percent fatal in 11
months and that no treatment there was
no evidence whatsoever that any
treatment radiologic chemotherapeutic or
surgical would help so that we all got
that dumped on us in about 10 minutes
and she just took that in and went on
walking and uh in fact I think she was
not really even overwhelmingly affected
by that until she had to tell Julian and
saw that reflected in him and that
really
changed her because she saw that that
made
made more of a difference to him than it
did even to her and so she saw the love
she had granted him because she was an
excellent mother reflected and that
really changed her life it might have
saved her life but it certainly
transformed her permanently and that
took a long time to unfold but Tammy is
a she's one tough cookie and she took
everything on the chin and Tammy
basically was at the edge of death for
three months every day she just about
starved to death during the recovery
process from her surgery because of a
surgical complication she lost about
almost 30 percent of her body weight and
she she did suffer a little bit with
post-starvation syndrome as a
consequence of that but
I don't think I ever saw Tammy
desperate or resentful during that whole
time
no and she she opened herself up she
accepted help where she could get it she
took every possibility to move forward
that was offered to her
um
she opened herself up to transformation
on every front and really did change and
I would say she's now doing better than
she ever has in her life it's really
quite miraculous to see the fact that
she also recovered and as far as we know
she's the only person who ever survived
this form of cancer incredible she said
she credits it I think this is worth
mentioning
um she it was the weirdest thing so she
got really sick it was horrible
um I wasn't around as much when she got
sick because I had PTSD from my Hospital
experiences and I didn't want to go into
a hospital I went to the hospitals but
like the PTSD was pretty bad
um and she she was stuck in the hospital
and she said I'm gonna get better this
is just such a strange story she said
I'm going to get better on our
anniversary which uh for Mom and Dad is
mid-august and this was June
and she told everybody this and we're
like okay mom like she's on morphine
we're like not sure what's going on
um and then they flew to the U.S to do a
procedure which didn't work and then on
their anniversary she got better
which was really weird because nobody
was expecting that and she goes oh it
was God
and converted to Catholicism that is
miraculous and it brings me back to what
I asked you when it was just me and you
talking which is whether you believe in
god what happened to your wife to Tammy
and her turning to God in that moment
did that not give you all the proof you
needed that
there is a God
well I was already very religiously
inclined before that I mean I've been
studying religious thinking for
40 years you know and speaking to my
students about that very
diligently during that whole time and
so in some ways I mean the anniversary
issue that was very strange yeah and and
the Transformations that have occurred
in relationship to Tammy are quite
profound and wonderful and and
hard to believe
um
was that additional evidence to me I
already had a lot of evidence you know
what we talked about in other uh I was
already a firm believer in hell you know
and I knew there was a route away from
hell and the root away from hell is a
religious pathway so I've been walking
down that pathway a very very long time
so this was just another not just you
know what I mean it's it's a milestone
and a marker but it wasn't for me that
wasn't a qualitative transformation
did you did you dodge the god question
in the previous interview
it was really interesting and in fact
it's almost like he's almost rewinding
now because I if I'd asked him right now
I may have got a different answer
because I think Jordan I think you do
believe in God and I think what's
happened to your family has reinforced
that belief but for some reason you're
reticent to just certain people modern
people don't don't understand this
question they think that it's a matter
of believing in a set of facts it's not
if you believe in God you allow the
spirit of the logos to take residence
within you
now but nobody understands what you mean
if you say that
but like think about it this way
Michaela could have got bitter and
resentful well the spirit of bitter
resentment is the spirit of Cain
because her sacrifices would have gone
unrewarded she would have been rejected
by God and she would have shaken her
fist at the sky and the spirit of Cain
is a luciferian spirit and it's it's a
genocidal spirit
and you can allow that Spirit to take up
its residence within you and that means
that you're a follower of the luciferian
spirit or you can do the opposite you
can allow the the spirit of the logos to
take residence within you and that's
what you're attempting to do if you
adhere assiduously to a genuine
religious practice okay Michaela and
that's real oh it's real let me ask
Michaela I mean you said to me did he
Dodge the question on God why did you
say that
just to see what his face would look
like if I said that while he was on
Piers Morgan
and his body language the arms went up
very quickly I noticed quite defensive
body language uh Mr psychologist
you gave her a chance to be annoying she
immediately took it well Michaela okay
explain why did you ask him about God
you asked me why
well I believe in God yeah and there and
I didn't before or I wasn't sure before
I was never an atheist but you know when
people say Do you believe in God I'd say
I don't know I don't really get it I'd
like to I always wanted to and so when
Mom converted to Catholicism and I saw
you know a whole bunch of really weird
things that I couldn't logic out
happened
um let alone dad becoming famous and
then us all getting so sick and an
unbelievable amount of suffering then
mum's miraculous recovery that she knew
ahead ahead of time by two months the
date of that nobody could explain
um yeah you learned at least that you
had no idea how the world were oh
absolutely none that's what I learned is
I don't understand what's going on at
all
um but I saw the transformation that
took place in mom and I saw how much
more compassionate she became because
she's a very disagreeable woman and I
wouldn't say compassion is one of her
strong suits and she became more
compassionate somewhat dramatically
and then I met to love everybody in the
world now it's very annoying yeah it's
nice uh and and so that was enough for
oh that wasn't quite enough for me
actually it was about a year later and
dad was so sick and uh
and I didn't know I had exhausted
everything I knew how to do to help I
couldn't think of any other way I could
help and I remember praying at that
point because I literally couldn't think
of anything else to do I was just just
like God help us help me
um
and I think it was around that period
where something switched and then my
life got easier and I don't know if
that's because I let go of some control
that I don't actually have
but my life switched directions and I
felt calmer in a way that I couldn't
describe or
come to any I couldn't figure out why
and I figured that was God so that was
enough for me to say
reality isn't exactly how we see it
there's more going on out there and and
Michaela if I ask you if I ask you
Michaela do you think your dad believes
in God what would you say
get it right
yeah I think so yeah I did see he
definitely he definitely I think so he
definitely lives in a way where he knows
that
if he acts as if he believes in God then
he avoids hell so I don't know what the
difference between that and belief is
why would you do that if you didn't
believe right
right seems reasonable to me right
Jordan
sometimes it's always good to bring out
the daughter because you'll get the
truth out of the debt
you know you can you can put the old
arms up to me Jordan down there from
America but you can't to your daughter
sitting sitting right next to you she
she knows you better than you probably
know very sneaky plan on your part
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to the special edition of
Piers Morgan uncensored with Jordan and
Michaela Peterson Michaela I want to
play you and say this is from a a
podcast in which you talked about uh
getting divorced it was very very
difficult to get divorced considering
what my dad talks about it made me stay
in a relationship longer than I should
have I don't agree with the more
conservative
story of divorce that people are being
told I think being in a relationship
that's not good for you I think you
should get out of that relationship
interesting that uh let me ask you
Jordan when you heard us say that did
you feel any responsibility that she may
have stayed in a very unhappy marriage
for too long because she didn't want to
upset you because of your views
no I wouldn't say so I
I'm able to let my children
handle the complexity of Their Own
Private Lives knowing at least
I think as I do that
there isn't that's a place where only
fools would would go
and I had faith that she would
sort things out you know and so I I'm I
was willing to give her her space I mean
I believe in committed marriage and so
um
at that level of generality
obviously I have objections to the
breakup of a marriage but you know I
have faith in my daughter and so I
believe she'll
I believe she's oriented to find her way
and finding your way is a complex
process and I'm willing to stand back
and watch her and to provide whatever
help I can along the way but also not to
interfere too much okay you're
uh are you you're remarried now right
yes and your name the name of your of
your second husband
uh Jordan Fuller
now conspiracy theories
you ended up marrying a man named Jordan
should I be reading anything into this
if I was a clinical psychologist oh I
have no idea like like I said before I
don't know how the world works I don't
think so my secretary is named Jordan
too this is very weird now everyone in
your world is Jordan so this is like
being in Barbie world
yeah
let me ask you it's Michaela because her
husband looks like Ken
is that true Michaela
yes
100 true yeah I want to play you both a
clip you your dad's had a lot of feuds
with people uh some he starts some he
doesn't some he gets just gets picked on
for the sake of it there's a lot of
feminists who he winds up very
successfully I would say because they're
very easy to wind up
um one of them is Caitlin Moran he's
currently in America and she's using
your dad a lot uh ranting away about it
I mean here's one clip of her talking
about your dad
he shared a piece through his 10 million
followers in which I think I do a pretty
good demolishment job of his entire
career in irva the advice that he gives
is either the kind of stuff your mum
would say for free like make your bed
pet a cat in the street or mad stuff
about lobsters I didn't even go to
school let alone University and I was
halfway through his book going I'm
fairly sure I can demolish a great deal
of the logic in this book this guy is
not the smartest guy in the world he's
just a man in a waistcoat who sounds to
be honest a bit like Kermit from The
Muppet Show
Kermit from The Muppet Show your
thoughts
well that's true I do sound a lot like
Kermit from The Muppet Show so that was
the one thing she said that that was
accurate that's not even her joke no
that's not clever if you steal it from
somebody else no it's an old joke but it
was a good one when it first came out so
what do you think of her
sounds like she'd be fun at a party or
with your mother yeah
yeah yeah Michaela
McKenna do you think people like Caitlyn
Moran do they just basically
misunderstand what your dad really is
about
I don't even think they're capable of
understanding what he's about
there's too much arrogance there you
can't be that arrogant and assume you
know everything and then read something
and learn or read anything and learn
right
that's why you don't cast pearls before
swine deer
you know Jordan my sons as I think I've
told you before are all big fans of
yours and they they just said to me they
got one question which what advice do
you give uh for children who are the
children of controversial public figures
well you know Michaela has leapt out and
and taken the opportunities that came
along with that in the public way my son
Julian is a more private person and he's
chosen to erect barriers around his
family and not to face the public as
much although he has played his music
out my lectures and and he works with me
I think you know each person has to find
their own way there are great advantages
to having a tremendous amount of
attention devoted to you and having
people offer opportunities but each
person depending on their own
temperamental proclivities has to figure
out how to manage that themselves and
it's complex but it can work I mean
Julian Tammy and Michaela have all
reacted to that in their own way it took
Tammy a good while like the rest of us
to figure out what her place was so to
speak but she's really managed that and
Tammy is out in public much more than I
would have thought she would have been
um
you know if I would have guessed if I
would have been able to see into the
future 10 years ago she's become quite
an accomplished public speaker for
example and she certainly didn't think
that was in her in her cards in the
cards or in the stars but um
things come at you and
you surf the wave and and you're happy
for the opportunity and
Julian and Michaela and Tammy have all
adapted in their various ways and I
think at the moment that's working like
a charm Michaela if I asked you great
Kelly obviously the family's gone
through this extraordinary
six seven years or more now involving
some extraordinary challenges for you or
personally which would have happened
anyway or perhaps not actually in a
dad's case but certainly for you and
your mum
um but you've come out and you've got
fabulously wealthier as a family I guess
than before this started fabulously more
famous than before it started but if I
had the power to transport you back to
anonymity
without the fame without the extra money
and all the rest of it would you would
you take that deal or would you be
actually quite happy where you've all
washed up now
oh I there's no way I would take that
deal uh even with everything we went
through I was talking to my husband the
other day about why I'm interested in
making money versus why he is and he
said he always liked expensive things
basically and I said I didn't I'm like
decked out right now but I also didn't
mind buying things from thrift shops and
decorating my room that way I didn't
want to feel vulnerable anymore from not
having enough money and so my yearn to
be successful was always so that I would
be less vulnerable so that when I had a
problem I had money to help me solve it
and that was my motivation
and so I wouldn't want to go back to be
before because I feel more secure and
less vulnerable now also the next just
the final part of my exclusive
double-headed with Jordan and Michaela
and things get emotional
[Music]
good evening upstairs Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail about working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS manages to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous it was
clearly something of the face of the
world so it was even more Unthinkable if
this nurse had misgendered somebody on a
board she'd have been out the door when
they first got together there were press
stories weighty Katie that would make
her a better princess of wealth because
you're not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job
resonates with people Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him
a conservative party can certainly win
the next election can we yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
foreign
[Music]
let it roll
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know I know you're probably going
to vote me off shorts
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
[Music]
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
when I'm in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has Battalion
materials you don't drink never taken
drunk you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
will I get a better interview roughing
you up a bit but I get the real Zlatan
then you want to play with fire I will
bring your fire but I will burn you when
I say I am God you think I'm joking or
not you tell me I'm not joking when you
score a goal is it better than sex sex
is better whoever thinks different he
has a problem with his sex
I'm the best
I'm Zlatan uncensored
[Music]
welcome back to An Answer special with
Jordan McCaleb Peterson wanted to ask
how much of a ham Michaela's had in
transforming her father's questionable
sartorial style one thing that money has
definitely bought you Jordan is a better
fashion sense I mean the the radical
change in you in the smart suits the the
crop the the hairstyle everything you're
really being drag Kicking and Screaming
into into the pinup world
well you know when I went out on tour
the first time I thought I'm going to go
speak to
you know a third of a million people and
I thought well okay
should probably be happy about that and
you should probably try to do it right
and Stage Show fundamentally it's in the
theater you probably deck yourself out
so I went and got a couple of very good
suits and
and that had all sorts of strange
consequences including over time that
most of the people many of the people
who came to my shows started showing up
in three-piece suits and relatively
formal attire which is a lovely thing to
see and and that that saying yes to that
and not and not being condescending
towards it you know I was never
overwhelmingly interested in fashion but
I didn't assume that I was morally
Superior because of my ignorance and
disinterest and and then because I said
yes to that a whole Avenue opened up
a whole Avenue opened up there in a
surreal and comical way and now I'm
having a really good time with it and
now you've reached so it's very fun it's
yeah obviously great fun and you look by
the way you look sharp so
congratulations
um thank you sir what you're both doing
now is this Academy tell me about the
Peterson Academy what what is the
Michaela for you what is the purpose of
this
uh the purpose is to
allow people a proper 2023 style
education I I think that what you learn
what you learn in universities generally
speaking is taught through an
ideological filter it's overpriced and I
don't think it actually improves you as
a person and I think generally speaking
you can say that for almost every
University and we have the ability now
to learn online from genius people so we
figured why not produce courses
that are extremely well edited allow the
professors to teach the way they would
want to teach without the guidelines put
in place on them by the universities and
then give it give access to everybody
and then anybody who's actually
interested in learning and retaining
that information to better themselves
has a place to go a social media
platform where they can meet other
people which I think will be very
interesting we don't know how that's
going to go
but I'm hoping it'll give people the
opportunity to learn and meet other
people who are like-minded
yeah we have great professors and and
one of the advantages to being in the
position that I'm in at the moment and
this is partly a consequence of my
podcast is that I can find great
speakers from all around the world
because I'm also touring around the
world and every time I find someone and
I think wow you're so interesting I can
hardly stand it I think how would you
like to come down to Miami and record a
lecture and right virtually everyone
says yes and then they come down to
Miami and we put them in the studio and
we treat them very very nicely and we do
that because we're actually happy that
they're there and we tell them you can
teach whatever you want the way you
would dream to teach if you if you could
have what you wanted and so then people
come down there and do that and they're
pretty happy about that and then they're
often willing to do another course well
why wouldn't they be so I just sort of
ask you both uh finally uh this really
is it's clear to me from interviewing
you both together you have an
extraordinary Bond
um you clearly love each other very much
you're a very tight family it's been
through a hell of a lot of challenges
but if I was to ask you Jordan and I'm
going to ask you Michaela the other side
ask you Jordan what is it that you love
about Michaela what would you say
foreign
she's pretty damn funny
she's tough man don't mess with her
she'll bite you and you'll remember it
so
she's a formidable person like my wife
like my son they're fun to be around
don't mess with them that's a pretty
good combination
it is Michaela what would you say about
your dad why do you love your dad
he's incredibly compassionate and open
so there's opportunity everywhere in a
positive way and he cares deeply about
everything that's going on
in people's lives
definitely you definitely have more
compassion for the average person than I
do
I I kind of think
come on there you're a hard ass maybe
maybe try a little harder that's that's
not what you think yeah uh so I would
say what I love about him is his
openness which has led our family I mean
to where it is now I think is him saying
yes to opportunity and being open and
compassionate
yeah what a great way to end uh thank
you both so much for all the time you've
given me uh I think you're a great
family I think you're an important
family I think in a world where people
are scared to express their opinions
they don't know what to think I think
both of you in different ways but also
and you have commonality too but in
different ways you're really having a
huge influence over millions and
millions of people around the world and
it's an influence I know you take very
seriously and it moves you both and I
think that's uh an extraordinary thing
and I wish you all the best in
continuing with that thank you both very
much indeed for joining Piers Morgan
uncensored
thank you very much Pierce thank you
the full-on cut uncensored version of
both of my Peterson interviews will be
available on the Piers Morgan uncensored
YouTube channel tomorrow another world
exclusive footballing icons Latin
Ibrahimovic in one of the most explosive
interviews of the year until then
whatever you're up to keep it uncensored
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]